I have five cats, and there are some things only cat people understand.
Like which meows mean what.
*meow*
Or how they love to interrupt you at the worst times.
Ghost, this is not a good time.
You know, we even know the best ways to cheer them up.
So I have five cats, I have Abby, Lilly, Jimmy, Congress, and then Ghost
So we got... *door bangs open*
Congress?
BAD KITTY!
I'm just doing sound, I'm gonna go.
*screams*
No!
Anna Akana I've come from the future to stop the feline wars
What?
How did you get in my bathroom?
You did.
Sorry, I...I thought you were gonna ask who sent me, so...
No.
Nevermind,
it's up to us to..
ugh fucking really?
Here kitty kitty, look here's your favourite toy
*machine shuts down*
Good boy.
//And thus began the reign of Anna Akana//
//She ruled the land with an iron fist//
//Some feared her//
//others worshiped her as a god//
//But that is a story for another day//